hi there
i'm still working on my korean here
didn't get a lot done today american
thanksgiving we were invited by our
kind american neighbors and some of the
people here where we live and we had a
american thanksgiving party this
afternoon and then i'm back home
but i saw an item maybe it was on
twitter
saying uh learn languages is one of
these sites promoting languages learn
languages it's it's it's better than
sudoku or something else in other words
learn languages it's good for the brain
better for the brain than doing sudoku
and i thought to myself the people most
of the people who do sudoku and i must
say on the airplane you see a lot of
people doing sudoku
i'm the only one studying languages on
the airplane the only one that i've ever
seen on an airplane studying languages
is me but lots of people do sudoku watch
movies read books and so forth but my
point is this most people who do sudoku
they like it
they don't do sudoku because they think
it's good for their brain i don't think
i don't think they continue doing it for
very long
if they thought that it was just
something good for their brain but they
didn't enjoy doing the sudoku so it's
the same with languages
don't do languages because
somehow it's better for your brain than
sudoku or because it's good for your
brain
learn languages
because you like to learn languages
you like it
not only because eventually you want to
be able to connect
in these languages with people of a
different background and explore this
whole world that we live in
but also because you find a way
to enjoy the process and if you enjoy it
you will continue to do it doing it so
don't do sudoku because it's good for
your brain don't learn the languages
because it's good for your brain
learn to do it
because you enjoy it and if you don't
enjoy well just don't do it
and that is all i have to say for today
i'm not going back to my korean i'm not
going to give up i got another whatever
it is 10 15 days
and i'm at my 45 000 known words i
promised i'd get the 50 000 i think i
may not make it but i better buckle down
bye for now